في روسيا بوتين يحول بلاده رويدا رويدا
الى كوريا الشماليه ثانيه وفق تقرير
نشراته صحيفه فاينان شيلد تايمز
البريطانيه والتي اشارت فيها الى سياسه
داخليه جديده تقود الديمقراطيه في روسيا
وتنذر بتحول سياسي وماساه انسانيه لطاقات
البشريه في البلاد ما يعني ان الرئيس
الروسي بلادي مير بوتين قد يحوله بلاده في
المرحله المقبله الى نموذج كوريا الشماليه
وفقه الصحيفه البريطانيه هذه السياسه
الداخليه الجديده تشمل عسكره المجتمع
وسيطره الدوله على الاقتصاد وعزل البلاد
والهدف واحد وهو احداث تحول جوهري في
السياسه الروسيه حيث اشارت الصحيفه ايضا
الى احتفالات ويوم الوحده الذي كان في
الرابع من نوفمبر الماضي والذي اتخذه بوت
سبيلا لتعظيم الذات والاذكاء الروح
القوميه واعطاء جديد للكريم لين يعزز
انشاء دوله استبداديه وفقه مراقبين غربيين
خصوصا وان قيام الكريم باغلاق ووقف انشطه
المنظمات غير الحكوميه المستقله واستخدام
كاميرات المراقبه لتعقب المتهربين من
التجنيد دليل يعزز توجهات ونوايا بوتين
غير المعلن عنها وهنا اشار متابعون
للتطورات الحاصله الى ان الوقت حان للقوه
الغربيه للتعامل بصرامه وذكاء مع تحركات
موسكو شديده خصوصا وانها تسير في اتجاه
جاع روسيا كتكوريا الشماليه ولكن كبرى ذات
ترسانه عسكريه تضم الالاف من الرؤوس
الحربيه النوويه
الذي اقام وقام بضم الاقاليم الاوكرانيه
الاربعه واعلن عن التعبئه العسكريه
الجزئيه لتدارك الاذلال العسكري الذي
عاشته القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا خلال
الاسابيع الاخيره يواجه مشكله كبيره تتمثل
في عدم سيطر قواتها على الاراضي التي قام
بضمها لروسيا وهذا يعني انه لا يستطيع
القيام باي تسويه ما لم يطرد الاوكرانيين
من تلك الاراضي وايقاف كلها جماعتها
[موسيقى]